well this is super exciting I have never
done anything like this on eg Canada
pride before I have three epic drag
queens with me right now I'm a little
scared because I know all of you are
very smart and very sharp so you're
gonna go easy on me do it throughout
this conversation right it's early in
the day we're slow don't worry I think
first and foremost the elephant in the
room if we may is miss Kovac miss Rona
is kind of ruining a lot of things for
us um how are all three of you doing
right now mentally physically throughout
this kind of self isolation period I
first want to thank you because when you
started just say that the there was an
elephant room started to you know a
little concern you were talking about
miss Rona we were opening it Jana ear
jinx or Dayla the three of us were
together when our show got canceled and
when we you know fully started to grasp
how big of a disturbance this was going
to be in our normal lives and we
immediately started brainstorming
together like how we were gonna get
through this and I could say at the very
beginning of quarantine I was a complete
wreck I was depressed I was freaking out
watching all my gigs just disappear
really stressed me out and what has
brought me back is the support of fellow
performers and the way we've all just
kind of snapped into action but also
very much the support and the loyalty of
my audiences and our fan base the fact
that like you know I started doing
Instagram live shows and putting my
venmo and paypal up because all my
income had disappeared and people were
just overwhelmingly generous you know I
got very emotional a couple times just
seeing how supportive people were being
well that's what I think is so special
about the queer community is that you
know we are a family and when something
like this happens
it really shows you just how much of a
family we are how much the queer
community can really support each other
but I love that we are creating new ways
to stay connected to each other and of
course a new way is wqu our queer
quarantine radio what's going on here
where's what no no I mean my husband
he's dead she's killed him now get ready
to be joined in heavenly matrimony again
surprise somebody who typically listens
to a lot of podcasts on but this isn't a
podcast on this is throwing it back to a
way of storytelling where I was sitting
there and actually envisioning what was
going on and that was super cool for me
as somebody in the audience
tell me about creating this and what the
idea behind it was I think all of us
were very sort of hit with the fact that
there are so many queens out there who
have been cultivating a strong
relationship with digital media for a
long time there are many queens who
create incredible like video content and
podcasts but we are all Queens who
really thrive in a cabaret setting and
in a theater setting we write narratives
we write characters right dial and so I
think that for us it was our economy
adapt to this kind of media that we've
seen other Queens thrive in but in a
very different way and how did he use it
to bring what we really have to offer to
the listener is that this time there are
a lot of people who are feeling very
alone and what this does is the first
episode I think was about 33 minutes for
33 minutes you don't feel alone when
you're listening to this you feel like
you are in this these stories you know
it's so imaginative it's really
incredible you three and major scale
should all be very proud of this because
it is fantastic
even we think we can all agree we want
you to um publish your review of our
show everywhere you can thank you so
much yes of course that was our our goal
you know we love creating I mean even in
our live shows I think in all three of
us and major four of us work together a
lot and we really really value the
escapists
opportunity we offer people with our
live events you know and so our goal
with this podcast was exactly that how
can we make people laugh how can we all
so cleverly sort of comment on what
we're all going through at this time you
know um we don't want to beat you over
the head with it but this still is
something that exists because of this
situation the pandemic and so the fact
that you were able to escape is like it
just it's music to our ears when this is
all over do you think you would ever
take this and do like a YouTube kind of
show of this or could this even go on
the road is it - uh yeah we've talked
about um doing live staged readings of
this and ways that we can continue this
you know like right now we don't know
how long quarantine is gonna last we
don't know how many episodes were going
to be able to produce in the time of
quarantine and we also don't know like
where it's going to go after quarantine
is list lifted but now that we've
created something you know the
possibilities are endless I already see
you know turning the murder at
Darlington mansion into a short film and
I also think it speaks to the fact that
like when we all start the three of us
and major scales when we started taking
to digital media you know it wasn't
gonna be us doing what everyone else
does with digital media like I can't
imagine myself doing a makeup tutorial
or a how-to video no unless I'm making
fun of it you know like I wouldn't be
able to be sincere but this medium like
taking our talents as live performers
and finding out where it fits into this
world of digital media has real
inspired me to find ways of taking what
I do well and filtering it through this
new medium I'm working with I feel like
we're really all excited about following
the path of this and letting it sort of
reveal itself and it probably will
manifest itself as some film work as
some stage work and maybe a live sound
performance which I think they're all
exciting directions we may head in two
of you are from the drag race family you
know which are you are you watching
season 12 and if so just give me a name
who are you rooting for um
gg-good I honestly see so much of myself
in her with the way that she's tackled
every obstacles so effortlessly oh hey
there if you want more LGBTQ news and
exclusive interviews click Subscribe or
watch these videos